l.a times l.a times has
one of the
spookiest headlines i've ever seen
columns reading mocking anti-vaxxers
covid deaths is ghoulish
yes
but maybe
necessary
and the picture is a young woman young
beautiful woman orange county gop figure
who died of covid
and he says we should mock her death
this is by michael hilsick not just some
crank
who wrote a letter to the editor this is
a pulitzer prize-winning
columnist
the original headline by the way which
you can still see in the url of the
article is why shouldn't we dance on the
graves of anti-vaxxers
why shouldn't we
here's what he says he says quote pleas
for civility are a fraud their goal is
to blunt and enfeeble criticism and
detract distract from its truthfulness
typically they're the work of hypocrites
it's almost the same argument that the
communist is making to whitaker chambers
don't don't give in
don't give in to those pleas for
civility
don't give in to those pleas for charity
it will blunt the revolutionary spirit
he goes on mockery is not necessarily
the wrong reaction to those who publicly
mocked anti-covet measures and
encouraged others to follow suit before
they perished of the disease the dangers
of which they belittled
nor is it wrong to deny them our
sympathy and solicitude or to make sure
it's known when their deaths are marked
that they had stood fast against
measures that might have protected
themselves and others from the fate they
succumb to there may be no other way to
make sure that the lessons of these
teachable moments are heard
i bet this guy michael hilsick i bet he
loves humanity he cares so much about
humanity
i'm
skeptical that he loves a single person
but he definitely loves
humanity
and that's why we need to mock their
deaths
in order because that will make us good
people if we mock the deaths of others
that will make us good people
because
while we'll hurt many many individuals
many many people we will
i guess help you man i'm not quite sure
how we see humanity we need a lot less
humanitarianism in our country we need a
lot more charity
ah you know what to do
the bell you got to ring the bell get
the notifications
you'll get all the new videos that come
out on this channel you go over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
what do do you type in the michael
knowles show
subscribe
maybe leave a five star review you'll
get totally uncensored content too hot
for youtube you'll get it all over there
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you